landesliga männer lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wie heute zum
zweiten teil von flaggen erraten
zusammen mit der geografie professoren
sammlers of europe die junge maria
eißing
zufahrt in du dich sehr
es könnte wohl auch sei
ich glaube dass nigeria
sind es eure holland nigeria dass indien
kleines land das muss man nicht
unbedingt das ist ja das nord oder süd
korea
ich sage auch
[Musik]
kurioses ist gefolgt von
dänemark bist du los dass österreich
lettland
sie ist es damit junge librettisten dort
nicht sagt 3 weil
lukas
sagen wir drei sie sagt über zwei das
richtig ich wirklich hab klappen des
islams ist
scotland verrühren island
nordsee herzen so zusammen
dass etwas zu deutschland war
willst du deutschland waren eingefangen
hinaus ein plätzchen wurde mainz
norddeutschland hatten eingefangen
das ist tokio
[Musik]
es ist wohl
gesagt okay ich sag ja
richtig japan
ja alles ja in tokio tokio sah das land
genau hat ja auch rechts ist
palästinenser das ist
schließlich wieder kohle nicht nur so
lecker angebracht
erst
einmal die mit meinen gedanken gucken
das könnte nordsee flagge war das ist
die nordsee
ist
ich sage das ist estland das ist richtig
ja
ich höre ich habe im lauf china estland
belgien alles meins die sterne klebt man
sich einig auf die
wahrscheinlich tragen jetzt mehr in
unserem podcast sogar spotify das lästig
und du kannst ihn ändern
doch marokko syrien
stimmst du
nicht willst ob das wusstest alter ab
[Gelächter]
mayer und co kg
ich sehe ich lieber nadel mit
der hand mein gesicht eingeschlafen ist
es nach libanon lieber noch so denn so
dass man auf das gerade so
sowie werden in rumänien so leicht sagen
du kein trikot 100 echt ist das syrien
genau das geschah
dann ägypten
das ist pakistan
pakistan dass die firma das wäre
irgendwie so ein parkhaus oder so
kennt das nicht
das ist denke ich weiß es auch ja sagt
zuerst anfangsbuchstaben a
und weiter das ist nämlich kolumbien die
bezirksregierung vollidiot
ksc seine tipps geben ja es gibt einen
film der so heißt
mailänder
ja
voll von madagaskar aber schon morgen so
meer und strand mit der flagge
eigentlich nein die waffe
sowohl türkei nee das ist nicht türkei
das ist dass neben türkei
gerade ihre tunesien und
tunesien iran jetzt bei dem format ab
die post das ist gott länder die
die whales
neuseeland new zealand pixar alter mann
ist für mich das neuen kontinent ist es
oft gemacht um das ist so bestätigt
worden allerdings
gedreht die wieder von drogen filme
mexiko mexiko nee das ist das ist mir
auch kamerun
casino war die niemals da haben die
chemie verguckt wussten nicht dass die
frage wie groß ist die besonderheit ist
verbrachte und also in welche es sieht
so habe ich für kekse gebacken wird ist
mir zu einem stern
report kukident
es ist es wir bleiben beim tck chile
das ist nepal
details zum buchstaben wo es bei den
bergen
mit aldata hey wie viel geld
die sind alle grün gelb brot das ist
jetzt jamaika
[Musik]
youtube waren die dings denken diese
tiere die so hören aber die mit einem
dünnen beiden
antilopen der so gesehen ist es weiß es
aber ich sage wenn dieses verlangen so
ok dann soll ich dir was sagte zuerst
und ich sage das ist
[Musik]
friesland
das ist meist land
das fast richtig das ist thailand haben
gesagt land ich weiß ich weiß auch
ganze staaten p ja okay danach kommt ja
ich seh ich ja
das volk ja dass in tunesien pulsuhr um
was es ist wir sind hier los ist so
flach
dahin zeichnen
[Musik]
was er dir dann die punkte zu mir
letzter punkt entscheidet wird ich weiß
nicht ob ich viel von drei runter ich
mach 3 2 1 sondern sagen wirke 3 2 0 1
und
wartet auf ihren netzen die frage
entscheidet
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der flammpunkt entscheidet
ich habe
gesagt ja das ist weißrussland
griechenland israel
die abitur sehr wichtig mehr menschen
okay
das
[Gelächter]
positive auch rot und grün oder
das marokko
bin ich mir auch schon dreimal
das ist tokio